(folk music)
- One time, I did a pull
up on some scaffolding
in the city, so I'm pretty fit.
- Wanna see me
one-bite this calzone?
I too am pretty fit.
- I read all of the Karma
Sutra and didn't jerk off once.
- I read all of the
Sauna of Ice and Fire,
and I can't say the same.
- Watergate was an inside job.
- A lot of people
think Christ was black,
and I'm cool with it.
- We have season four of
Entourage back at the house.
- And an old molly pill our
friend Kenny Wu gave us.
- We'll split it four ways.
- This is fun, but we
have to go tanning.
- You guys just
came from tanning.
- You don't get us.
(phone rings)
- Oh wait, we'll be right back.
- Just wait.
- Wing Shop.
- Hey.
- Uncle Sal, uh.
- Why are you cheese
dicks at the Wing Shop?
I'm getting calls from customers
saying that you're closed.
- Uh, yeah we're
here, it's fine.
Everything's fine here.
Um, the people are calling,
we don't know why
they're calling,
because we are here, so.
- Oh, come on guys.
The Long Island above-ground
pool volleyball tournament
is next week, and
Wings is sponsoring it.
This will finally put us
on the Long Island map!
- Oh yeah, the
volleyball tournament.
We were just about to
start training for that.
- Well, you better!
I got some serious cheddar
riding on your pale asses!
- Ladies, we'd love to
stay here and try to get
handjobs from each of you,
but we gotta get back to work.
- You could come check
us out in the Long Island
above-ground pool volleyball
tournament this weekend.
It's at our mom's house.
[Both] - Ooh, we like jocks.
#
- Do you blend raw eggs or raw
chicken to make you strong?
- Uh, let's try both.
- Aw, a circle of life shake.
(blender whirring)
- Yeah.
- Ugh!
- Dude, it's time you start
converting this to muscle,
and I've got just the thing.
- I got this from a disgraced
Russian javelin thrower
that I met online.
- Aren't you concerned
at all about drug testing
or anything?
- No dude, as long as we use
low doses, we're gonna be fine.
(shouting)
(techno music plays)
(hip-hop music plays)
- Sign right there, yeah.
- Here you go.
- Thank you, my dear.
Oh, don't forget
your Wings coupon.
- Thank you!
- Complimentary
foot rub with that!
Go ahead, girl.
(growling)
Hey, boys, so now you
come late for a tournament
in your own backyard?
- We got next.
- You better not be
peeing in those cups.
What do I need with your pee?
- For the drug test.
- Guys, there is no drug test.
And this doesn't
even look like pee.
Jesus Christ, guys, what are
you doing to your bodies?
- Training.
- Eating.
- You want next, you got next.
The Lombardo brothers.
- Hey, gonna be a
good game right?
- Let's have some fun.
(growling and shouting)
- We gotta impress these chicks.
(shouting)
(rock music playing)
- We're here to have fun,
right guys, that what we're--
(shouting and splashing)
- We got to keep a lot of
the registration fees, 'cause
everyone ran in fear.
- So, we won.
- I feel like human garbage.
- I had two distinct heart
attacks during that rampage.
- I've been ejaculating
water for an hour.
- Man, there better not
be any wings in the pool.
- Danny, Mark.
[Both] - You guys looked
pretty wild out there.
- Wanna go to your bedrooms?
- I think you mean
bedroom, that we share.
- Or we could just give
you guys handjobs out here.
Whichever you prefer.
- Uh-Oh, I best be
getting out of here,
give you guys some privacy.
- See ya.
- Thanks, uncle Sal.
- I think we're gonna go with--
[Both] - Handjobs.
(video game music)
- If you like what you see...
- Click to subscribe.